le big bang une formidable explosion par
laquelle tout aurait commencé il y à 15
milliards d'années une fantastique
libération d'énergie donnant naissance à
l'univers l'univers un monde en
perpétuelle expansion
un espace infini dans lequel des
milliards et des milliards de galaxies
continue aujourd'hui encore à s'éloigner
les unes des autres à des vitesses
vertigineuses démis rien de planètes aux
paysages rudes et désole un monde sans
limite
constitué d'une nuée de contrer à violer
l'univers c'est une fabuleuse aventure
et bien des mystères qui hantent
l'imagination des hommes depuis la nuit
des temps
l'univers en question c'est bien sûr
d'abord de savoir comment il s'est formé
il y à 15 milliards d'années c'est le
début de l'histoire et des histoires ça
a toujours été fort mais c'est toujours
comme ça y'a pas eu un cataclysme qui a
provoqué ça je constate c'est toujours
comme ça et là
mais au vu de tout cela
marseille
autre question ses dimensions sa taille
immense étape à deux ça pas de grandeur
7e fini en hausse vers midi et puis
enfin à quoi ça ressemble
c'est une boule de feu moi qui se plaque
planet michael caine
découvrir univers c'est d'abord
s'intéresser de près à ce qui se passe
dans notre quartier
c'est à dire dans le système solaire une
tête des pagnes dans l'immensité de
notre galaxie constitué de plusieurs
centaines de millions de soleil comme le
nôtre une galaxie si vaste qu'il
faudrait plus de cent mille ans pour la
traversée même lancée à la vitesse de la
lumière
plus de mille ans avant notre ère des
savants et érudits établissent le
premier répertoire des étoiles de notre
voûte céleste
des données corroborer et précisé plus
tard par des astronomes grecque comme
hipark utp l'aimé
e
épousant la conception du cosmos qu'en
avait faite en mai mais on considérera
jusqu'au 16e siècle que la terre est
bien le centre de l'univers
le soleil n'étant d'une planète parmi
d'autres
gravitant autour du soleil neuf planètes
de taille différente
la terre étant la troisième en partant
du soleil
observer le ciel c'est donc d'abord
mieux connaître l'unique étoiles dont
nous ayons un certain nombre
d'informations en vue directe
celui qu'on appelle l'astre du jour et
qui est aussi à l'origine de la vie sur
terre le soleil
à 150 millions de kilomètres de nous le
soleil qui lie à 4 milliards 600
millions d'années faisait régner sur
terre un véritable enfer de dante
puis il y à 500 millions d'années c'est
l'apparition de la vie et la poursuite
de la transformation lente mais
progressive de notre planète
une métamorphose spectaculaire découlant
directement de l'activité solaire c'est
dire toute l'importance de mieux
connaître les mécanismes qui régissent
le coeur de notre étoile et son
environnement
le soleil c'est une source de chaleur
absolument considérable de l'ordre du
million de degrés qui dégage en une
seconde
autant d'énergie quand consommerait les
états unis en trente mille ans cette
énergie créée par fusion forme
l'héliosphère une zone d' influence dans
laquelle le vent solaire et le champ
magnétique de l'étoile domine l'espace
interstellaire pour analyser cette
héliosphère encore bien mystérieuse non
plus en deux mais en trois dimensions
l'agencé spatiale européenne et la nasa
ont imaginé un engin spatial qui
sortirait du plan de l'écliptique c'est
à dire du plan sur lequel évoluent les
planètes autour du soleil permettant
ainsi à une sonde d'aller pour la
première fois survolé le soleil en
passant par ces deux pôles
cette sonde c'est du lys elle a été
lancée en 1990 par la navette spatiale
américaine
la manoeuvre la plus délicate a eu lieu
en février 1992 elle a consisté à
utiliser jupiter comme une fronde en
faisant passer ulysse tout près de la
planète et de son champ magnétique très
puissant
ainsi accélérer la sonde une fois sorti
du plan de l'écliptique devrait
atteindre la banlieue du soleil en 1994
pourquoi des fonds énormes de placement
des versatile de temps à autre dans
l'héliosphère quels mécanismes physiques
régissent les éruptions où les vents
solaires ces questions et à bien
d'autres qu'ulysse devra tenter de
répondre en étudiant de près
l'environnement extérieur du soleil
ce vent solaire piéger par le champ
magnétique de la terre on peut en
observer les effets près des pôles
ce sont les aurores boréales
autre mystère le site d'apparition des
taches solaires tous les 11 ans et les
normes gravité qui règne à ces endroits
précis une gravité trois mille fois plus
forte qu'ailleurs
on mesure ainsi tout le chemin qui reste
à faire ou 120 chercheurs des quarante
quatre instituts appartenant aux douze
pays qui travaille actuellement sur le
programme ulysse
observez les particules et les champs
magnétiques de régions encore inexploré
comme celle des deux pôles du soleil
dont la polarité s'inverse
mystérieusement tous les onze ans c'est
bien là toute l'originalité du lys qui
pour la première fois vera le soleil
dans sa troisième dimension celle des
pôles un fabuleux voyage très chaotique
au milieu des émissions de rayons x de
particules énergétiques de rayon et de
poussière cosmique de bouffées de rayons
gamma et de gaz interstellaires
quatre ans après avoir quitté la terre
ulysse devrait atteindre le pôle sud du
soleil en 20 94 et met aux cinq mois
pour le traverser passage à l'équateur
en février 95 et survolant fin du pôle
nord de notre étoile
de juin à septembre 1995 quantifier et
cartographier la galaxie qui nous
entoure
c'est depuis la nuit des temps dans cet
univers en perpétuel mouvement
un véritable cauchemar pour les
astronomes exemple l'évolution de la
constellation de la grande ourse ont
seulement trois cent mille ans
autre problème la précision de
l'observation gêné au sol par toute une
série de pollution physiques dues
notamment à l'atmosphère d'où l'idée des
scientifiques de lézat de mettre en
orbite une véritable machine à
cartographier le ciel
son nom hipparcos la précision demandé
mille fois plus précis que la seconde
d'arc
par comparaison le diamètre angulaire de
la lune vue de la terre est d'environ un
demi degré d'arc plus parlants site du
haut de la tour eiffel on pourrait voir
l' empire state building de new york
l'angle serait 100 fois plus petit soit
de l'ordre de 20 secondes barque
enfin une balle de golf posée au sommet
de l'empiré state building et vue de
robes à 6500 kilomètres de là aurait un
diamètre angulaire encore dix mille fois
plus petit soit une milliseconde bac
exactement la précision demandé à marc
os 3 millions et demi de fois plus
perçant que l'oeil humain
hipparcos a été lancé en 1989 par la
fusée européenne ariane
et malgré les difficultés rencontrées au
début de sa mission il devrait fournir
la position la parallaxe et le mouvement
propre de quelque 120 mille étoiles avec
une précision de 2 à 4 millisecondes et
d'environ un million d'autres étoiles
avec une moindre précision
il part cause c'est un véritable piège à
cartographier les étoiles dans lequel
elles sont obligées de tomber il faut
environ une vingtaine de secondes à
chaque étoile pour traverser la totalité
du champ de vision du télescope hambourg
reporter chasseurs d'image y par contre
coupera jusqu'à 150 fois ces
informations pour s'assurer avec
précision de la position de telle ou
telle étoile
l'intensité de la lumière qui traverse
la grille du télescope et échantillonné
1200 voix par seconde et le détecteur
des toiles passe de l'une à l'autre en
s'attardant sur celles dont la source
lumineuse est la plus faible
chaque étoile à sa phase c'est-à-dire sa
propre empreinte digitale un certificat
de naissance qui permettait au parc
hausse de remonter le temps
l'art témoin de son temps avec en
pressant un cette fresque du célèbre
peintre italien giotto la première
présentation scientifique de la comète
de halley le passage d'une comète comme
les éclipses de lune ou de soleil ont
toujours donné lieu à des manifestations
de peur ou de superstition
il faut attendre les travaux de
l'astronome anglais et demande à l'est
et la fin du xviie siècle pour découvrir
que les comètes apparu en 15 131 ses 107
et 782 n'était en fait qu'un seul et
même objet l'avenir devait donner raison
à alet et en 1758 malheureusement après
sa mort sa prédiction se réalise
ainsi au rythme lent des 76 ans les
scientifiques du monde entier attendent
désormais l'événement
dernier en date 1986
parmi les 1000 comme est répertorié
celle d'un alley est la seule qui soit à
la fois très active et dont leur bid
puisse être prévue avec suffisamment de
précision pour déterminer la trajectoire
d'un satellite destiné à l'intercepter
après un peu plus de huit mois de voyage
giotto qui est le premier satellite
européen à s'affranchir de l'attraction
terrestre arrive dans la queue de la
comète et c'est la toute première photo
le monde entier suit l'événement en
direct
giteau plonge maintenant vers le noyau
de la comète et c'est la première photo
faite par la caméra multicolores
rencontrer nos ventes avec un des
ancêtres de l'univers car la composition
chimique des comètes a très peu varié
depuis la formation du système solaire
il y a quatre milliards et demi d'années
en effet elles ont passé la plus grande
partie de leur vie en hyper congélation
à une distance du soleil
cinquante mille fois supérieure à celle
qui sépare le soleil de la terre
les chiots taux qui s'enfonce dans le
coeur de l'immense boule de neige sale
et maintenant littéralement bombardés
par une véritable pluie de classe son
bouclier anti choc et percutait en
permanence par des myriades de poussière
de comètes mêler aux cristaux de glace
et puis c'est la collision
miracle joao baty mais il est vivant et
après une période d'hibernation yoto est
réveillé en 1990 pour préparer son
rendez vous en juillet 92 avec une autre
comme est celle de greg drop
sonder l'univers profond c'est aussi
étudié l'intensité du rayonnement des
étoiles qui le composent rayonnement x
notamment pour exane un autre satellite
scientifique de l'agencé spatiale
européenne
pour exane il faut détecter les sources
d'invisibles de rayonnement des
longueurs d'onde inaccessible au sol
comme celle très énergétiques émises par
des amas de galaxies ou des naines
blanches leur signature étant un flou
très violent de rayons x
beaucoup des toiles vive par paires et
la mort de l'une d'entre elle provoque
la libération d'une énergie gigantesque
et une nouvelle naissance
le résultat de cette explosion
thermonucléaire d'une extrême violence
une étoile à neutrons ou un trou noir un
monde binaire de deux objets plus grands
et plus massive que notre soleil
mais si proches l'un de l'autre qu'il
serait physiquement lier un système
stellaire extrêmement dynamique et donc
très chaud dans lequel les deux objets
seraient déformé par leur champ
gravitationnel voilà la théorie autre
théorie celle des pulsars des étoiles à
neutrons très petit mais possédant une
masse considérable et surtout tournant
sur elle même à des vitesses
vertigineuses de l'ordre de 1000 tours
par seconde là encore mystère
des énigmes que pourrait tenter de
résoudre à son tour iso un observatoire
spatial de lagence analysant cette fois
les sources de rayonnement infrarouge
peut être découvrirons-nous ainsi un
monde invisible celui de la masse
manquante de notre galaxie
un monde encore bien mystérieux dont l
iceberg nous ne verrions aujourd'hui que
les 10% de la partie émergée
m
non
vous
oh
pour regarder aux confins de l'univers
on l'a dit les télescopes même les plus
perfectionnés comme celui des îles
canaries sont myopes et leurs yeux sont
comme brouillé par les effets de
turbulences et de distorsions dues à
l'atmosphère
en effet dans l'espace les étoiles ne
s'indigne pas en supprimant ainsi les
effets atmosphériques altérant les
images prises par les télescopes
classique on devrait avec hubble x 10
nos connaissances
apple mesure 14 mètres de long et 4
mètres de large pour un poids de 11
tonnes à bâle a été placé en 1990 sur
une orbite de près de 600 kilomètres
d'altitude par la navette spatiale
américaine
les amas de galaxies éloignées telles
qu'on peut les observer avec un
télescope classiques devraient préciser
leur forme le ciel pourrait ainsi peu à
peu s'éclairer dévoilant peut être
l'existence d'objets à la présence jusqu
alors à soupçonner
on devrait pouvoir observer des spectres
d'objets lointains tels des étoiles ou
des galaxies l'inconnu plus près de nous
la planète géante saturn
à gauche l'image prise de la terre donc
à un milliard deux cent cinquante
millions de kilomètres au centre la même
planète prises par la sonde américaine
voyageurs à 35 millions de kilomètres
enfin à droite l'image que devra en
donner à apple du grand spectacle en
perspective
malheureusement un problème sur le
miroir principal de hubble fait que les
premières photos reçues ne sont pas de
la qualité escompté des images cependant
pour les non-initiés absolument
extraordinaire d'une des étoiles les
plus chaudes de notre voie lactée
quelque chose comme 200 mille degrés
à la mystérieuse croient d'einstein de
véritables joyaux de l'univers
autres constituants de l'univers observé
par hubble les objets quasi stellaire ou
casar
des mondes très étrange que ces objets
qui sont les plus éloignés que nous
connaissions ces quasars semble
renfermer une énorme quantité d'énergie
et certains sont même suffisamment chaud
pour produire de très grande quantité de
rayons x et de rayons gamma
certains de ces quasars seraient attirés
par de gigantesques trou noir
faut-il ainsi les considérer comme une
autre classe d'objets coexistant avec
les galaxy classic ou constitue-t-il une
phase évolutive et précoce de la
formation des galaxies des questions qui
restent aujourd'hui encore sans réponse
autre type d'objet mystérieux altaïr
cette étoile de la grande ourse à seize
années lumière de nous et bleu alors que
notre soleil et jaune
d'où vient la source d'énergie qui anime
ce système des toiles double là encore
pas de réponse autre interrogation le
système complexe de castor dans la
constellation des gémeaux à quelques
mille années-lumière de distance
sa configuration est tel que quand on
observe du sol
castor semble être un système binaire
comme sirius alors que vu de plus près
il s'agit en fait de 6 étoiles groupés
en trois paires enfin autres
constituants de l'univers les plus
grandes des étoiles les géantes rouges
500 fois plus grosse que notre soleil
sont elles des étoiles en fin de vie se
gonflant tel de monstrueuses bull
gazeuse dévorant tout sur leur passage
notre soleil de ira-t-il dans plusieurs
milliards d'années
un de ces objets là encore bien des
mystères en regardant ainsi plus loin
dans l'univers apple devrait nous
permettre aussi de remonter le temps en
s'approchant peu à peu de l'inaccessible
big bang
on
la fabuleuse aventure de l'univers c'est
aussi celle d'une de ces milliards de
milliards de poussière qui le constitue
la terre
une planète désormais sous haute
surveillance écologique de satellites
spécialisée qui l'a scrute nuit et jour
dans ses moindres détails
des images de l'atmosphère qui
l'entourent prises toutes les demi
heures par le satellite de l'agencé
spatiale européenne meteosat
des images transmises au centre des
opérations meteosat de darmstadt en
allemagne images d'observation du disque
terrestre dans la bande visible mais
aussi dans l'infrarouge analysant plus
particulièrement soit la vapeur d'eau
qui entoure la terre soit les
températures des terres des océans et
des nuages
des éléments de base de la prévision
comme le déplacement des nuages mais
température de la surface des mers
l'humidité de la haute troposphère les
indices de précipitation ou l'analyse de
la couche nuageuse
des images qui font désormais partie de
notre vie quotidienne
autre observatoire privilégié de la
terre rs à satellite de la nouvelle
génération chargé de surveiller
l'environnement de la planète bleue
jusqu'à la fin du siècle une orbite à
800 kilomètres d'altitude passant par
les deux pôles et survolant à période
régulière tous les points de la terre
des photos d'une qualité et d'une
précision extraordinaire une imagerie
tout temps des terres des glaces et des
océans
des prises de vues permettant de mesurer
voire de prédire de façon fiable
l'ampleur et la vitesse des
modifications des processus influence
sur l'environnement
étude approfondie des terres émergées
mais aussi des océans véritable
inventaire d'une planète dont les
ressources sont limitées et de plus en
plus sollicités en surveillant en
permanence les transformations de la
planète bleue c'est satellite de la
terre comme météo ses atouts rs devrait
contribuer à la sauver
avec la sonde huygens du nom de
l'astrophysicien qui en ces 156 a
découvert l'anneau de saturne
c'est le monde fabuleux dans la proche
banlieue de la terre des sondes à dire
planétaire après un voyage de sept ans à
bord du véhicule spatiale cassini la
sonde huygens réalisé par l' agence
spatiale européenne sera littéralement
éjecté de cassini et dirigé vers titan
le plus gros des dix sept satellites
naturels de la planète saturne titan une
sphère orange de 5000 kilomètres de
diamètre encore bien mystérieuse
al'approche la haute atmosphère de titan
la sonde huygens dans sa course
vertigineuse sera alors freiné avant de
poursuivre sa descente au bout d'un
parachute avant de se poser sur titan
huygens n'aura alors que quelques heures
pour décrire ce monde qu'on pense
aujourd'hui glace et à l'atmosphère
opaque mais dont la composition est
voisine de l'atmosphère primitive de la
terre
tout au bout de la nuit noire au plus
profond du ciel et de ces 15 milliards
d'années une lueur un repère à témoins
l'explosion originel le big bang une
date de naissance de la fabuleuse
aventure de l'univers dont il reste
encore aujourd'hui à déchiffrer bien des
secrets
m